All right,
welcome everyone to Wednesday nights
again Henderson after a long summer hot summer
away we're back. And so thank
you for being here.
At this this Venture into
something that we'll talk a lot more about over the next few minutes and get
to practice a little bit as well. Phil will
say a lot about that. But I just wanted to kind of give a context for
this allow us to all be
on the same page about why we're here what we're doing in this if you
did not get a binder. Those are
at the back at the table. Make sure you go talk to
Jill especially there may be somebody else back there. I can't see but Jill especially
back there will help you get kind of the resources
and also contact information for you
just so we can help you along the way. So if you did not
get a binder make a journey back there in the next few
minutes to grab one of those and get what you need. Just so
you can have the things that everybody else has and what he'll be talking about.
but again, remember this as we call it
disciple making 101, this is really
the fruit of a long journey that God's taken me on
but also I think God taking our church on over the last
few years. You've heard me say this for the last four years about
disciple making that's what God led me to do my just my
doctorate on Dr. Ministry at Southeastern
Seminary on disciple making relationally and
so God was spurring that on and a lot of ways for me for a
long period of time then God brought
Phil here just a few months ago who has a
doctorate in disciple making as well who studied this and practiced in
a local church. And so God is just been putting all the pieces together
that we've seen in kind of behind the
scenes form for the last four years, but now
it's it's starting to take on a big
public part of who we are as a church
and that's really exciting to me and you'll hear feel say a lot more about that. But as
we get into this, I wanted to set a tone set a
vision for this and I want you to think about
rhetorically questioning you right now, but in
your mind, just think about
that's that time in your life.
Where you can identify you grew the most spiritually.
I just think about okay. What was the setting who were the people
involved? What was the context? Where was I? How old
was I just just think about that for a second?
Kind of identifying your mind. What was that situation?
and
I've asked that question probably 10 12
times as I've spoken different places talked about disciple
making I've asked that question and then I'll have a dialogue at times
with people.
And 90 plus percent of the
time the answer is pretty much the same.
Every once while you get a couple like, you know, I was I was at this church in college
and it was really just a powerful time of worship
every week and the preacher and those kind of things but 90 plus
percent of the time. It's it's a form of this.
It was that that time in my life where that Sunday school teacher
invested in two or three of us every Sunday
afternoon, and we went to their house and we just met together
and talked about the Bible.
Or it was it was my mom sitting
down with me every week and we had a discipline
time of time in the word together.
Or it was me and a couple college buddies and we walked together through all
the way through the Bible together in a year and we just kept growing
and and those were the most formative times and it's like
90 plus percent of the answers are some form.
Of that smaller group that relational environment.
And so that is what prompted me to
do my studies. I think the same fulfill like thinking about
if that is the primary Place most of
us have grown spiritually then where is that in the church?
Why is that not happening more regularly if that's
for most of us when we grew the most?
Shouldn't that be a part of the pathway in the
church? It always happens kind of outside and para church
or we we want it to be a part of what we do
here.
So that's what this is beginning to start. We've like I said
been doing this a little bit behind the scenes for a few years with a few people starting
to get some things working. But really we needed
somebody like Phil to be here to help oversee the
pathway and help develop and train and and encourage
and equip you and me
towards this end.
Because remember our our mission is to equip one
another.
to love Jesus and live sent
so it's not just us as a staff or Elders equipping you.
It's equipping one another.
So that's all of us with all
of us.
To help each other love Jesus and live sent in more effectively.
So this tonight is the beginning of of revealing that
pathway of kind of walking us as a church towards disciple making
as you'll hear all of us have been called to
This is not new information. You've heard me say this you've heard
us talk like this at church. That's now our our vision is to become
this hub for an all ages disciple making movement that
would glorify God, right? That's where we want to
head. And so what is disciple making
is part of that conversation. That's why we're here.
So I'm just so excited to see all of you here for
that.
I would encourage you challenge you this is
gonna put you in a place that you maybe haven't
been before challenging. You towards something. It's
okay, right?
We stay in a box and we get a little comfortable. This
is going to push you a little bit towards something that we
we know according to God's word according to
all of our experiences with that we know is going to to notch
some growth in our journey.
So I want to challenge you towards that.
Even when it gets hard, it gets a little uncomfortable. You have to push yourself
a little bit. That's okay. That's growth and God wants
to do that in US.
And so Phil's going to come explain a lot more about how this is
going to work. But I just wanted you to hear my excitement
over this this is what we've been praying for
and dreaming for for the last few years. And now God's put
the pieces together. We believe towards a pathway to
make disciples who make disciples who make disciples.
That's the definition of a movement that it passes on generationally and
we want to see that happen from here and through
here and to the ends of the Earth as we
go forward in this so be encouraged by that if you
again if you didn't get a binder head to the back grab one of those Phil, why
don't you come out ahead I'm gonna pray for you and then we'll get
going. Okay.
God thank you so much for what you have done already
in Us in so many ways. I look back to those men
in my life around the age of 20 to 23
and that season of time where you were just using these
guys to pour into me and then ever since
then.
As you radically transform my life through that that ever
since then there's been these these markers these few
guys just gathering around at Brahms at
6am and just talking about what it means to follow you Jesus looking
at your word applying it praying going on
Mission together like that.
Got to have seen it in me. I know so many in this
room have seen similar things made that become normal for us.
That our church sees that that we as a body become
disciple makers.
That every one of us has the responsibility may you open
our eyes to see that even more than we have
before?
We look forward to how you're going to use Henderson Hills
towards this end of of growing each
other as you work in us and through us.
This is only your work God's not ours. But but as you use
us as vessels as tools towards that end in each other's lives. We
see spiritual growth happen, but then we see unbelievers come
to Faith and grow. We see people sent to the
ends of the Earth sharing the gospel God. We we want this to become.
What we do every one of us this is expected. It's
normal to pour Our Lives into somebody else.
To follow you first ourselves and
to pour Our Lives into somebody else.
So help us be encouraged in your word in
your spirit by one another that we would do this with our
whole lives and our time and
our effort and our resources God you would be glorified in
us. That's what we want more than anything that our lives look more
like you Jesus bringing more glory to you.
Pray for Phil. I pray that as we journey through this over the
next couple months that you give us Clarity give us understanding give
him wisdom how to instruct and give us willingness to
be challenged to step outside of the the
Comfort zones that we often stay and got
challenge us towards these ends in Jesus name we pray.
Amen.
Thanks, Phil. Amen. Let's give our
professor hand.
I was hoping for more John but that's going to have to do.
so one of you was so excited about discipleship that
when you got your
when you got your workbook when you wrote your name down you left your
cell phone on the back. So feel around for yourself and look in your purse. If
you don't have a cell phone, this one has a lovely picture of
a of a silhouette of a
bird. Anyway, I want
I want to see who it is. I want to embarrass you really bad right now.
All right anybody? Okay. Well, it'll be at the back.
But I wanted to blame us being late on
this cell phone but Dynamic do with
it at all. So we're gonna look real quickly. I
have a plan that we're going to work this plan every
Wednesday night now it'll be for our Port
our part will be 12 weeks, but there'll be two weeks
that we take off one for fall break and one for a family equipping time
that's in your schedule in your book. But today we're
going to just look very quickly at the Jesus
purpose for the church. It's most clearly
described in the Great Commission, which is Matthew 28,
18 19 and 20 and but
it's in every passage. I mean in every
gospel and if you'll see there in Mark 16
and Luke 24 and John 20, the Great Commission
is included in every gospel
and it's very clear that God utilized
the church to accomplish
his purpose and he doesn't just expect
it. He equips the church
And he empowers the church to achieve his purpose.
And what is that purpose Go Make Disciples
to the ends of the Earth. So discipleship is
not a program that occurs on Wednesday nights at
6:15. It's not a program that occurs on Sunday
nights. However, how many of your old enough to remember when we called Sunday
night church disciple training anyone. Anyway,
I see that hand. I see that hand. Yeah, you're give
showing your age. But but let's
talk a little bit about the Great Commission.
First of all, the the issue of authority is
100% settled.
Jesus says all authority in heaven
and on Earth is given to me. So he is
King Jesus. We are citizens in
the kingdom of God. He's King Jesus king of
kings Lord of lords Prince of Peace. He is
our Lord and so it's not a mistake that he
links his perfect Authority with
his commission to make disciples. And
so we go and make disciples. But now I
want you to understand the context real quickly. Jesus has
been tortured he's been whipped.
Crown of Thorns bloodied cross
he's died. He's buried and he's risen again
from the grave to give victory over sin and
death and then you would think after having
accomplished all that. He would just go into Glory into heaven
wouldn't you but that's not what he does all
of the gospels record that for a month.
He makes appearances post Resurrection
appearances and he validates
the truth that he is the Son of God by living again,
but also by saying I want
to clearly articulate my mission
for my disciples and and
that is to make disciples. And so one thing of
Pastor John has been asked me to do is to help clarify what
what we've been calling for a long time the road map
to disciple making and I ask permission
for us to stop calling it The roadmap because
that's old technology. Right? We all
have GPS right now. So you talk
to your kids about a road map. They're not gonna know what you're talking about. So we're
gonna call it the pathway and here's the pathway really
quickly the worship service
of course is not going away. It occurs
on Sunday mornings and it is our largest attended assembly of
the week somewhere in the neighborhood of
1500 to 2,000 people depend.
which weekend and it's it's an
amazing thing that we get to experience, but we
also have
Various groups that meet for various
reasons last Wednesday night. We had a back to
school gourmet hot dog contest and I'm
not quite sure where that fits in
the Great Commission, but it was a lot of fun wasn't it?
But we'll have other meetings and we call
these equipping groups of Men's Ministry groups women's ministry groups, but
Sunday mornings, this is when most of our
people are going to attend got new technology here.
So we're going to see how we do. Okay, but but we're
going to try on Sunday mornings to push people to other
events, but we're not going to be satisfied with
just people showing up on Sunday mornings and going to our
big events. They may be most inclined to come to me big
events. But what we're trying to do is to do what to
push them to community groups. How many of you by rays
of hand are currently involved in the community group
raise your hand. Okay. See that's not that's not an
accident. We believe that the community group is where
you get connected relationally.
With a group of people who you can love and be
loved by whom you can invest and be invested in whom
you can care for and be Cared by this is
this is on purpose. But but what we're going to
do with Community groups in the coming days is we're
going to work at trying to have
a discipleship coordinator in every community
group that is encouraging and celebrating people
who get involved in what will be talking
about for the next 12 weeks. And that is
this from Community groups. We're going to ask people to try to
get involved in these micro groups now micro groups
are gender-based.
And they have an intentional leader.
And a relational environment and a reproducible process.
And so this is
going to be our sweet spot right here and I'm going to try to explain
why there is one-on-one and clearly one-on-one
is the very best feature for being able to
be
completely invested in connected with another disciple
maker. But but we're gonna Focus this in these
next 12 weeks on micro groups and the reason why and
again I want by the way, this is
a
Is important news right here? Okay. I'm not
going to be the only one Speaking from the platform on every Wednesday.
I'm doing it today because this is the first one but a
good discipleship process is a reproducible process.
And so I'm going to do this enough to wear
one of you is going to learn how to do this. And then you're going
to do it for everybody else and we're gonna celebrate the fact that you learned that
disciple making Essentials are an intentional
leader.
Everybody say intentional leader.
Not bad. I'm proud of you. All right
a relational environment.
and a reproducible process
All right, you fell off you started strong
and then you kind of died out toward the end. But let me
explain that a little bit. Okay, so in the large group,
we have a very precise and
well-planned day every minute
is planned for our worship services
on Sunday. Our equipping groups are also
planned and typically there's one speaker on
the platform and everyone else sitting and listening now,
there's not anything wrong with that but it it can't
be enough in the disciple making process why it's
a relational process.
It begins to occur more effectively in
the community groups because there's conversation. What
do you guys think the passage means there? How
can we apply this in a way? How do we pray for
one? Another's you begin to get into the lives of one another in our
community groups, but in the micro groups if they're
gender-based and if they're intentionally smaller if
there is an intentional leader, who knows what the
purpose of the group is and if
you create a relational environment and then it
reproduces then we have the
opportunity for what I
would consider exponential multiplication. And
so I just want you to see that is
where this pathway is headed. And what
are the key features of a genuine discipleship
experience? Well, they're right here a it's relational.
B it's transparent
What does that mean? That means that I'm going to let you in to
who feels fully really is when I stand up
in front of people on Sundays. You don't get to
see everything there is to know about feel because frankly,
I'm not telling you and you don't want to know
right but if I can trust a group
of men who I know care for me whose purpose
is to develop me spiritually, then I
might be more honest with some things that I'm struggling with to the
point of vulnerability. I'm gonna tell you what
my weaknesses are so that you can encourage me.
So that you can challenge me and
ultimately you can hold me accountable.
the ultimate
goal
for disciple making is genuine spiritual intimacy.
Now. Let me talk to the
men for a minute. I'm a baby boomer. If
you're a millennial, I apologize for the
way we've treated you for all these years. But what we've
done is Baby Boomers is we've decided that it's the
tough guy that wins and the
tough guy is the guy that stands remote and aloof and
never gets hurt. My generation can be hammering a
nail and hit our thumb.
And say man, that's smarts.
You know when we're alone, that's not what we say. All
right, right. We we scream and we cry and
we jump and we there might be a curse word probably
not but maybe right so but
but when we're transparent and when we're vulnerable and
when we're intimate, we don't mind letting people in to
see who we are. So let's let's here's my last.
Example the larger the
group. This is like an X Y axis the
larger the group the smaller the opportunity
for intimacy.
And accountability and conversation
as a matter of fact on Sunday. If you guys
decide to have a conversation during Pastor John sermon the Usher
will escort you out right but but
watch what happens as the group begins to
grow smaller, then the opportunities for
transparency and conversation and intimacy
and accountability continues to grow.
So what we're going to work at doing at Henderson Hills
Church is pushing men into men's group
and women into women's groups so that they
can experience genuine intimacy.
And what does that look like?
Well, that looks like conversations.
And that looks like a transparency.
And that looks like vulnerability. And by the
way vulnerability is not something that is easy.
I'm gonna go ahead and write accountability so I don't forget it. Okay, but
I I just want you to be I want
you to understand doesn't come easy to me either.
All right, is it I wasn't raised by Alan Alda, you
know to to cry every time there was
a Sentimental moment on television some of you are too young
to know who Alan Alda is he was the very first man who cried on
TV or something like that out of it anyway Mash anyway.
It's doesn't come easy for me. My wife and
I've been married 42 years and she will tell you that I
have somewhere in the neighborhood of six to
eight hundred words a day.
All right. She on the other hand has six.
Thousand to 8,000 words a day. And and
so what will she's always trying to draw me
out and she's in she'll encourage me like a cheerleader. Come
on Phil stay with me and I'm just like, oh, please
leave me alone. Right? I want
you to know that's who I am really, but but
I know that I need to be in a group
of men who can know me.
Who can challenge me? I've been
in enough discipleship groups and we've grown close enough
together that I can tell
by the look on your face, whether you're full of the Holy Spirit or you've
grieved the Holy Spirit.
And it's it's a good thing. You're like, oh, I
don't I don't I really need people not to know that about me.
Right, but it no it's a good thing and if you want to grow in your
faith in Christ, then you're going to be willing to to focus
on this this sweet spot. We
call this The Sweet Spot and it is
probably the most difficult spot to
ascend.
What's going to happen next? All right is we've talked
about the pathway, right? We've talked about the essentials.
What is the essentials and intentional leader? I
want to go back to that for a minute. My prayer
is is that everyone in this room?
Will one day eventually be an intentional
leader of a micro group.
Okay, and some of you are already saying.
I'm out.
I'm not going to do that. Right and I
just want you to be I want you to be sensitive to
to the reality that this might be
what God is calling me to do. I may
not be ready yet.
But one day I pray that I will be ready. Okay, and
the best way for us to do this and I want
to be very empathetic the best way for us to
do this is to begin to practice immediately. Okay. So
what does that mean?
I got a great story and we're 13 minutes
over already. So you'll have to subtract your
time from your micro group. But what does
that mean?
Okay.
In a moment. I'm going to ask several of you who I
know are disciple making leaders to
stand.
And what not yet when you
stand I'm going to ask that you just kind of find a spot
around the perimeter. Okay. It looks
like we may have about 250 people
here tonight. And if you do the math if that
was 300 people, that would be about 75 quads.
I don't know if that's right or
not, but it's close.
All right. We probably have more
we we need more leaders. It's
like oh no, it's a huge failure and fill as
a complete flop move back to Texas. No really.
We all what we're
going to need in these causes for someone to say well, I'll
be the leader tonight.
He said well, I don't think I'm trained.
Compare your training with that of the the original
disciples.
Right what what training had they been through?
All they did was hang out with Jesus for about three years.
Right, they'd not been to Seminary they'd not been to didn't
have graduate degrees. They had not really ever been trained
by Phil sleigh School of disciple making 101, you
know, they didn't have a lot of training but they just decided
that we are going to invest in one another and
we're going to do life together and then we're gonna
reproduce that in groups Beyond to the
ends of the Earth and they did and here we are on the other side
of the Earth.
somehow in between that model
and where we are today, we turn discipleship
into kind of a program.
And what I'm asking you to do is to think with me
could this be a lifelong process where
I'm investing my life into
the lives of others and I want
to finish this story then we'll bust real quick. So this was
my last estopship group This Is Us actually sitting
in the dirtiest IHOP in the Dallas
metro area. We loved it because there was no
one there and so we always got right in and but
one morning this guy right here,
his name is David Bailey shows up
and David announces to us. His marriage is over and he
gives us lots of reasons why and he
takes 45 minutes to explain it. He ruined the
entire morning.
Okay, and we're all sitting there looking at each other like man. This
was a waste of time.
Well David would come and go and he would come and go
and he he came back one morning. And he
said this he said guys at
the end and we'll do that again tonight at
the end. You have prayer time together we ask how can we pray for
one another and David said I need you to pray for me because something's going
on. I don't understand it. So what do you mean? He said? Well,
I could never get my wife to go to church with me. That
was one of the reasons why I figured like I needed to divorce her.
and he
he said Sunday. I'm sitting in church by myself and
she texts me. Where are you sitting and she
came in and she sit next to me and she held my
hand.
He's like what am I supposed to do that?
And he said that night he says I'm staying upstairs. She's
staying downstairs and master bedroom. I hear the master bedroom open and
then I hear somebody coming up the stairs and I frankly I'm
hoping it's her.
It was my three-year-old.
Which is this little guy right here Sloan?
And Sloan stands at the doorway and all I can see is
her silhouette and she just stands there and he doesn't
know what to say.
Finally after about two minutes. She goes. I love
you, Daddy.
He said I love you. Sloaney and Sloan went back down got in
bed with Mom.
And David turns and he goes, I don't
know what this means.
maybe God is
want me to get back with my wife and and some
of us are going like yeah, duh. I mean come on
you the head with the two before?
And but listen to this at that exact moment right
next to him Rusty Wallace, that's Rusty
right there.
Rusty says David from the very first day you started
coming to our discipleship group. I pray that God would reconcile your
marriage.
I said David if you and your wife will come in and see me for marital counseling.
We'll pray for you and we will help you one day restore your
marriage.
And then we'll come to your wedding.
And guess what?
About six months later. I've been seeing them every other Sunday about
six months later. He goes. Hey,
On Sunday, we're doing counseling right because yeah, he's our we're gonna do that culture for
appreciation thing. You do every week. I said, yeah. We are he goes.
Well, I'm gonna ask her to marry me see why we
were being while we were counseling while we were discipling. They
had pre-purchased a divorce.
Package from a lawyer and they'd gotten
divorced.
But still they were committed to changing to transforming
to becoming Disciples of Jesus and he falls
on his knees and my office invites her who are to this
opship and this is their wedding and I just want to see this little group of
men right here. That's the discipleship group and we're in the we're in
the pit of covid. There's only about a dozen people there and there's
five of us from the discipleship group. And so there's
a there's David and his sweet
wife and they're two babies and God save their
marriage and they're still growing and still meeting every Tuesday
morning at 6:30 for this hour ship and
one day David will be leading his own discipleship group and you
don't tell me that that's not something that God gets excited about
so I think he wants to do that over and over again in our
own lives Okay, so
What's going to happen next? I'm just talk to you about courage and boldness.
All right.
Pastor Phil is going to ask you to find
a micro group of people in this
room men with men and women with women and
some of you're saying if I had known he was
going to do this. I would not have come.
Okay, and I'm I want
to say two things. First of all, I'm sorry.
And secondly, I'm not sorry. Okay, because the
hardest things
Are often the best things?
And if this is where we're moving then we're going to have to
say I'm going to I'm gonna put my big boy pants on tonight and
I'm gonna find a group and I'm gonna sit down with them and we're gonna start
discussing things and I'm going to have to participate I
would just much rather. Listen to Phil tell
funny stories, right? That's not discipleship.
And that's not going to progress our dream and
our vision of becoming a disciple making movement. So
are you ready?
Oh, wow. That was yeah. Yeah.
This is a man with a
very clear guilty conscience. And so thank you. I'm proud
of you. All right. So if you are a if
you are have been discipled and you
know what I'm talking about and you're excited about leading a
micro group in here on Wednesday nights at
during the second half of what we do together. We're gonna
have that you go ahead and stand men and women. All right, go ahead and stand.
All right.
Okay more men than women. I'd like to I'd like
to point that out. We're gonna need more women leaders. And so if
you leaders would kind of move towards the the
outskirts of this room. All right, watch them
walk. And if you see somebody that you know,
Then you're gonna in a minute gonna want to hurry to their group.
Okay, because when there's
four in their group, then you're going to have to find another group. All
right, so
Next what I'm going to do is I'm going to say go where
you feel. I'm gonna say something else.
This is awkward.
But it won't be awkward when you're the intentional leader
because you will be inviting people to be a part of your group and
you're going to invite people from your community group or from
people in your sphere of influence. You're gonna know them you're gonna
have prayed that God would lead you to them. So this is awkward right now.
It won't be that awkward later. But right now it's awkward. I know
that it's awkward, but what you're gonna see in
the next
12 weeks. This is an intensive, which
means it's not going to be 12 months. It's going to be 12 weeks. But
what you're going to see is this brand new
awkward micro group is going to kind of
bond together and fall in love with one another at
the end of the 12 weeks. It's over. Okay. This is not a group
that continues go on right but right now it's
going to be awkward, but you'll see how the Holy Spirit bonds and
unites the hearts of Those who commit to
growing in the image of Christ. And so next what a
life for you to do is to stand up and find
again, these are gender-based.
And so if you're a go to it, if you're a female go to
a female leader, if your male go to a male leader, if you
can't find a female leader, then guess what you're the new
leader of that group. All right.
So let's find a spot.